hey everyone persia here and season 11
of apex legends is literally packed full
of new content it's got a new map a new
legend changes to the weapons and
legends that we already use and so much
more so go ahead and leave a like
subscribe and let's go over everything
that's headed our way
storm point takes us to planet gaia
which contains deadly creatures and is
also the home to caustic and crypto this
map is the fourth and largest battle
royale map coming to apex legends and is
also the first map to be developed after
the release of the game since storm
point is 15 larger than world's edge and
doesn't have any balloons to travel from
gravity cannons add that extra boost of
movement to the outer areas of the map
and near the beach side when using the
gravity cannons you'll be able to use
any of your weapons or abilities which
could make for great plays or great
escapes there's also going to be
tridents in play as well and when i said
15 larger that's 15
more playable space not just overall
size however the northern half of the
map increases in elevations that even
valkyrie can't fly over which means
you'll have to make more calculated
rotations when rings start to pull that
way each individual poi almost feels
like their own unique map at times with
different design styles and elevation
variety continuing to be a theme within
each town there's also a lot more open
space directly underneath buildings that
will make those areas easier to play
when the inside or the roof of the
building is occupied and you're in a
pinch in those final rings storm point
also features natural wildlife that adds
a slight pve element to the map prowler
and spider nests can be found in
multiple areas that will be marked on
your minimap so you can choose to land
there for some extra goods or just avoid
them all together inflicting damage on
these creatures will not only grant you
a very small percentage of points
towards your evo shield but will also
grant you smart loot smart loot is loot
that drops from the wildlife that will
be tailored to the gun that you killed
it with whether it be a scope an ammo
type or other attachments the wildlife
definitely looks terrifying in the
trailers but they don't do too much
damage i think you could really only go
down to them if you happen to go afk or
something so don't worry about that but
if you do engage in fights immediately
around a prowler nest you do increase
the chances of getting third partied by
a prowler which isn't really the best of
things but definitely possible so be
careful
the newest legend joining the apex games
is ash who some fans may remember from
titanfall 2. we learned through various
comics and cinematics that ash also has
close ties to horizon pathfinder and
probably more that we'll learn about in
the future ash is designed with her
ronin titan in mind and it's interesting
to see how they've incorporated her
background into her kit similarly to how
they did with valk let's start with
ash's passive marked for death this
passive makes a death box icon show up
on your minimap and full screen map
whenever a player dies if you choose to
go to that location you can use ash's
pilot knife to scan the death box and
reveal the location of the death box's
killer there is a cool down on scanning
the death boxes so you would have to get
to the boxes within a certain time frame
to scan for more targets if you are
scanned you'll get a notification on
your screen which may indicate that ash
and her team might be on the way to get
you ash can only scan a box one time but
if he wipes an entire squad she could
potentially scan you three times ash
provides an interesting amount of intel
that will help you keep tabs on your
enemies but will require a little bit
more of an aggressive approach to get it
the ark tether is ash's tactical and
this thing is definitely gonna throw a
wrench in the game plan of movement
based legends the arc tether has a 24
second cooldown and is a projectile that
shocks an enemy and will tether them to
the ground it moves at a fairly quick
pace and in a straight direction which
means you can even throw it into the air
if you want to hit an aerial target the
tether can only target one character at
a time but it goes quite a far distance
so if you scout out the faster legends
of an enemy team you could contain them
and keep them in the fight just keep in
mind that the tether will only slow down
the enemy if they try to run outside of
the arcs range so be prepared for a
fight
ash's ultimate is called the phase
breach and this produces a portal based
on ash's line of sight but what
differentiates it from a portal like
wraith is that the phase breach can only
go one way and ash will always go
through the portal once it's placed it
can be really clutch for diving in or
out of fights quickly and repositioning
the whole team in a snap the speed of
the ultimate puts an emphasis on using
it at the most optimal moments possible
and that is why i can see ash being a
great legend for the person on your
squad who calls all the plays
season 11 also comes with some changes
to another legend watson watson has
actually received a number of tweaks
that might lead to a higher pick rate in
the coming months first off you'll be
able to use her fences faster and more
frequently as the cooldown has been cut
in half and the placement range has been
increased by 50
slowdowns when readying and placing
fences have been completely removed
which pretty much means instant fences
watson's ultimate is getting some
changes too instead of being on a timer
the trophy system now has a health pool
but you won't be able to place multiple
watson olds down at once the shield
regeneration you get from standing next
to her oil has more than doubled so
you'll be getting shields back much
faster making it even better to use in
reaction to heated fights to stay alive
okay let's talk about the newest weapon
the car smg this weapon is one of the
most versatile guns in the game as you
can use both light and heavy weapon
attachments in ammo you'll do the same
amount of damage no matter which type
you use but being able to expand your
options with full light and heavy items
makes looting a lot easier especially on
drop you will have to toggle between the
two so it's not like it loads
automatically just keep that in mind in
my opinion the car feels like it sits
somewhere between the r99 and the r301
and feels great in those short to
mid-range areas
the car may be the only new weapon
coming into season 11 but it's
definitely not the only thing that's
gonna shake up the meta for season 11's
arsenal the supply drop rotation is
changing the triple take is returning to
the floor as an energy marksman weapon
and the g7 scout is taking its place but
it's coming back with a little bit of a
damage boost and double tap early game
crate weapon rates have increased from
25 to 50. mid game has increased from 50
to 75
and late game has increased from 75 to
100
but the devs did note that the creepers
are not really going to be a part of
this increase of raid and they're going
to be kept in line so don't worry about
that
the l star is getting a much needed nerf
the barrel effectiveness will be reduced
the damage is being reduced from 18 to
17 and the size of the bullets will no
longer expand over time the longbow will
also be receiving a 5 damage nerf and
the eva 8 is getting a nerf to its fire
rate there's also going to be a new hop
up that will allow the mastiff and the
30 30 to reload two bolts at a time
instead of one so it's gonna be a lot
easier to clutch things out if you need
a few extra shelves and the peacekeeper
is also getting some changes in its
favor the pellet size is being slightly
increased the choke time is reduced from
1.5 seconds to 1.25 seconds and choked
up shots remain tight for slightly
longer when exiting ads crafting is also
getting a few changes if you're gonna
craft for ammo you'll now get a full
stack instead of just 20 but it is gonna
cost a little bit more in materials if
you like to level up your evo armor it's
now also going to cost a little bit more
but you're going to get
150 points instead of 100 which means
you'll never leave an area without a
blue shield if there's a crafter nearby
and if you like to drop hot well there's
an increase in the amount of gold loot
that is gonna spawn in the hot zones the
devs said hot zones can sometimes feel a
bit lackluster so we're injecting more
high tier loot into these dynamic zones
to make them more enticing drop spots
and if you want some ranked details well
we've got those too there will be two
season splits with storm point running
from november 2nd to december 21st and
world's edge running from december 21st
to february 8th there will also be some
changes to how ranking points are gonna
work too kill rp values will now take
your rank into consideration so if you
kill someone who's a higher rank than
you you're gonna get more points for it
for example if a plot player kills a
diamond player that kill is gonna count
for 12 instead of ten the kill rp cap is
being raised from six to seven however
the kill related rp cap can be reached
in different ways depending on tier
differences and placement so placement
is still crucial and you still have to
place first to have a chance at a max
total rp and for those of you worried
about losing more points if you die to a
lower rank player you don't have to
worry at all that's not taken into
consideration and only the killer
receives a modifier on their points but
the grind should definitely be more
rewarding now
[Music]
so many cool things are on the way for
season 11 of apex legends and i honestly
can't wait november 2nd just cannot get
here soon enough let me know down in the
comments below what your favorite thing
about this update is going to be and of
course leave that like and subscribe so
you don't miss any future apex news here
on gamespot thank you so much for
watching and we'll catch you next time
[Music]
you